les français qui devront attendre
néanmoins le 19 mai pour pouvoir se
rasseoir à la terrasse des cafés et des
restaurants le maire de paris la mère
pardon de paris avait décidé de faire
payer l'extension de ces espaces
extérieurs aux restaurateurs déjà en
difficulté anne hidalgo s'est finalement
ravisé hier dans le journal du dimanche
mais d'ici là d'ici là réouverture dans
deux semaines la question fait débat en
france c'est le pour et le contre ce
matin entre thierry de dolo d'eau
président de l'association de défense de
montmartre et du xviiie et romain vidal
secrétaire général du groupement
national des indépendants de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration en
ile de france regardez les associations
dont fait partie le réseau vivre paris
et la sodefor département marque
francour la réouverture des terrasses
éphémère pour nous d'ailleurs le 16 mai
les attardons sa cible et c c'est pas là
que se situe la controverse les taxes
d'utilisation des forces publiques de
terrasses de restaurants et de bars sont
relativement faibles
c'est très bien d'ailleurs pour les
restaurateurs mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec le loyer qu'il paye pour l'heure
pour leur occupation des espaces
intérieurs d'immeubles c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle un certain
nombre de restaurateurs utilise beaucoup
l'espace extérieur parce que en fait
même taxe était extérieur leur coûte
moins cher que l'espace intérieur
tout ce qu'on demande à la mairie de
paris c'est de revenir à un rythme
payante accès pas trop rapidement et pas
trop fort car malheureusement on sait
que paris la ville la plus touchée de
france et que le secteur de la
restauration est le plus touché dans
l'économie française
donc on va travailler cet été avec les
mêmes bases que 2020 avec une perte de
+2 48% 70% par le même de certains
restaurants cet été donc il faut pas que
les taxations des terrasses arrive comme
il était avant la cohue de 19 avant le
coup vite 19 on pouvait se permettre de
payer des terrasses très cher
malheureusement
c'est très bien qu'avec cette extension
de terrasser ce protocole sanitaire nos
terrains seront beaucoup moins rentable
on n'aura pas de touristes avant 2023
d'après l'office du tourisme de paris
donc nos terrasses vont être très
compliqué entretenir et à rentabiliser
donc payés oui un juste prix oui mais si
possible en 2021 et si essayons de faire
quelque chose de plus auraient liste
pour nos commerces
[Musique]
certains contestent le reste c'est le
caractère le caractère de au contraire
au droit à des trafics d'avoir cédé
cesser ces années c'est pas important
c'est en tout état de cause il n'est pas
question de donner gratuitement les
spots public
l'activité des restaurateurs est une
activité qui a une base à l'intérieur
d'une même parce qu'elle a ils ont leur
cuisine leur fonctionne une plus grande
partie de la machinerie et en est à
l'intérieur et il paraît que même
illogique d'avoir une activité
complètement extérieur pouvoir
ineffective l'extérieur donc maintenant
on sait qu'on rouvre le plus rapidement
possible les restaurants à l'intérieur
et il faut savoir que les droits de
voirie était toujours taxés ça fait
partie des impôts on l'a payé chaque
année
l'année dernière on est une exonération
de taxe de voirie ce qu'on peut appeler
historique les classiques avec en plus
un geste pour tous les restaurateurs qui
n'avaient pas de terrasse donc les
extensions de terrasses donc ça
permettait à ce qui n'allait pas tarder
en avoir une et ça permettait à ceux qui
en avaient une petite en avoir un peu
plus grande faille dernière on avait
réouvert au mois de juin un qu'avec nos
terrasses également donc on est habitués
malheureusement à commencer par cette
étape
ensuite est-ce que les terrasses c'est
juste c'est une mauvaise que c'est une
nouvelle étape pour nous pas ça dépend
de chaque commerçant de chaque
restaurateur le point de profits et
encore un chacun c'est compliqué à dire
les petits établissements ne sont pas
obligatoirement les plus touchés par
cette époque parce que parfois on
travaille tout seul dans son bistrot
donc avant une terrasse et quelques
tables ça permet déjà de travailler et
faire et ne pas faire que de la vente à
emporter les grandes brasseries où les
grands cafés ils ont un peu plus de
terrasses laquelle seul le seul problème
c'est savoir quelles sont les aides
d'accompagnement pour la réouverture
puisqu'on va travailler avec en sachant
qu'un récent sur deux pas de terrasse et
en sachant qu'on va travailler avec une
jauge et un protocole sanitaire qui va
supprimer plus de 40% de nos places
assises même en terrasse donc quelle est
cette jauge de rentabilité comment
va-t-on l'obtenir grâce à
l'accompagnement des aides et puis le
deuxième point c'est malheureusement
pourra pas reprendre tout notre effectif
des premiers jours dès le 19 mai une
grande partie va devoir rester en
activité partielle
certes on la fera tourner on essaiera
d'autres tenir et de re faire travailler
tout le monde on pourra pas reprendre
tout notre personnel